politique
bonsoir et bienvenue dans les deux
politiques votre rendez-vous politique
du dimanche soir sur Radio sensation en
association avec TV 78 ce soir épisode
235 mon invité et le maire modem de
Villepreux Jean-Baptiste à Monique
[Musique]
politique
bonsoir bonsoir Quentin merci d'être
avec nous dans les deux politiques vous
êtes le maire de Villepreux et le
vice-président de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines délégué au transport et aux
mobilité durable vous êtes aussi le
président du MoDem dans les Yvelines à
l'actualité c'est toujours la réforme
des retraites alors à l'heure où nous
enregistrons cette émission le débat se
poursuit à l'Assemblée nationale on ne
sait pas encore si la motion censure va
être votée ou si les débats vont être
prolongés normalement en tout cas le
texte arrivera au Sénat le 2 mars des
débats animés on l'a vu dans l'hémicycle
au cours de ces deux dernières semaines
plusieurs groupes se rejetant la faute
les uns sur les autres sur la longueur
des débats qu'est-ce que vous en avez
pensé vous en tant que depuis Villepreux
c'est vrai la à l'heure où on enregistre
cette émission on sait pas ce qui va
advenir de ce texte ça fait plusieurs
jours qu'il y ait en débat à l'Assemblée
nationale il reste encore 3000
amendements au moment où on se parle
avec les difficultés c'est que les
débats doivent se terminer normalement
ce soir là on se parle il est vendredi
je ne sais pas dans quel état le texte
arriver au Sénat on a vu qu'il y avait
une obstruction parlementaire notamment
de la France insoumise et du
rassemblement national depuis le début
de l'examen du texte quand on dépose dix
mille amendements c'est pas 10000
amendements constructif personne n'est
Dieu moi je salue plutôt l'attitude du
groupe communiste qui avait d'ailleurs
déposé un certain nombre d'amendements
et qui a décidé de les de les retirer
justement pour pouvoir donner à
l'occasion à ce texte d'aller au bout je
crois qu'il faut quand même rappeler
la grande ligne et les grandes
orientations de de ce projet de loi
d'abord ça part d'un impératif et je
crois que tout le monde est très attaché
au système de solidarité français c'est
de sauver le régime de retraite en
mettant justement le système à
l'équilibre aujourd'hui on a 346
milliards de 346 milliards c'est le coût
des retraites aujourd'hui parents en
France il y a 30 milliards qui sont
financés par de la dette chaque année ça
représente à peu près 20% par an de
l'endettement de l'État français c'est
évidemment pas un modèle qui est
soutenable et durable pour les
générations futures
surtout à l'heure où vous aviez dans les
années 70 quatre actifs pour un retraité
aujourd'hui vous avez plus que 1,7 actif
pour un retraité ça veut vraiment dire
qu'il y a un problème de financement si
on veut préserver ce mécanisme de
solidarité ces dépenses aujourd'hui que
j'évoquais 346 milliards
juste pour que tout le monde se rende
compte un peu des ordres de grandeur
c'est 8 fois le budget de la défense 5
fois le budget de l'Éducation nationale
et ça va re peu pour ça représente à peu
près 11 fois les dépenses qu'on consacre
à l'environnement et à l'écologie donc
on voit bien qu'il y a un système à
réformer et qui a un système à sauver
après il y a évidemment plusieurs sujets
il y avait le sujet des régimes spéciaux
et je crois que là on s'y est attaqué si
je puis m'exprimer ainsi où il y avait
un sentiment parfois d'inégalité
d'injustice entre les différents régimes
reste encore pour moi deux zones d'ombre
ou en tout cas de sujets sur lesquels on
peut encore progresser la pénibilité et
évidemment le travail des femmes qui ont
des carrières hachées et là le modem
justement a fait quelques propositions
que je trouve très intéressantes qui
permettent de valoriser ne serait-ce que
le congé maternité notamment peut-être
leur octroyant des trimestres cotisés
supplémentaires mais il y a eu des
avancées depuis le début quand même du
débat on peut pas laisser entendre ça je
veux dire on a un âge légal aujourd'hui
de départ qui est prévu à 64 ans il faut
quand même rappeler que en France on
espérance de vie et une des plus longues
d'Europe avait plus de 82 ans et que on
est un des pays où on parle plus tôt à
la retraite 62 ans alors que la moyenne
européenne est 66 ans mais il y a encore
des sujets sur lesquels on peut avancer
faut pas oublier non plus que c'est une
réforme qui se veut être une réforme de
justice sociale ça je crois qu'il faut
absolument le rappeler et là je crois et
c'est pour ça que je trouve que la
proposition récente du MoDem va dans le
bon sens qu'il faut envoyer un message
fort quand même à celles et ceux qui
manifestent mais qui considère que cette
réforme est peut-être pas encore abouti
en tout cas dans dans l'esprit de
solidarité de dire qu'il faut que tout
le monde contribue c'est l'augmentation
peut-être d'un point peut-être de moins
des cotisations patronales pour que
aussi les entreprises puissent
participer au modèle de financement ça
je crois que c'est important on avait
calculé à peu près un point c'est déjà 9
milliards de recettes ce qui veut bien
dire que ça peut aussi nous aider à
remettre le régime à l'équilibre alors
cette réforme elle avait été bien bien
entendu annoncée par Emmanuel Macron
lors de la campagne présidentielle elle
a du mal à convaincre les Français en
tout cas selon les sondages d'opinion
que l'on voit souvent alors malgré son
impopularité les défenseurs donc comme
vous donc vous faites partir appel sans
cesse ou en importance pour maintenir ce
fameux système c'est pas une réforme qui
fait plaisir c'est quoi une réforme qui
fait plaisir c'est une réforme qui est
essentielle c'est-à-dire que la réforme
permettra au régime aujourd'hui d'être à
l'équilibre en 2030 si on ne la fait pas
c'est en 2057 qu'on va avoir qu'on va
avoir éventuellement un équilibre donc
c'est évidemment un enjeu certes de de
finances publiques mais également
d'autonomie de notre état mais comme je
le disais c'est aussi un enjeu de
justice sociale
moi je suis assez partagé sur sur
l'opinion des Français sur sur le sujet
c'est vrai que si on fait un sondage et
il y en a eu on était plutôt aux
alentours de entre 60 et 65% des
Français qui s'estimaient en tout cas
qui se disaient être opposé à la réforme
mais quand on regarde après
profession par profession branche par
branche catégorie de population par
catégorie de population c'est beaucoup
plus nuancé c'est pour ça qu'on parle de
la réforme des retraites c'est pas de la
réforme de la retraite parce que
finalement on voit que à chaque
situation quelque part il faudrait
presque alors c'est impossible mais il
faudrait presque des réponses alors si
tu les particulières ce qui est
évidemment pas le le
l'ambition parce qu'on pourra pas le
faire ainsi moi j'entends j'entends
certaines revendications c'est ce que je
disais notamment sur l'aspect social des
avancées ont été faites je je on peut
citer les abords Elizabeth borne la
première ministre qui déjà a réussi à
faire passer des pensions à 1200 euros
donc il y a une revalorisation de du
montant attention et puis pour les 43
les 43 années de d'années de cotisation
qui sont plafonnées notamment pour ceux
qui ont commencé à rentrer dans l'emploi
un peu plus jeune donc on peut pas dire
qu'il y a pas eu de débat en revanche
moi je suis très inquiet parce que
encore une fois à l'heure où on se parle
on peut sortir de l'Assemblée sans texte
ça veut dire qu'on ne sait pas sur la
base de de quel texte le Sénat va
débattre normalement celui du
gouvernement normalement c'est ça c'est
le gouvernement qui décidera en tout cas
exactement celui du gouvernement mais
vous imaginez bien que si les choses ne
se passent pas mieux au Sénat parce que
le timing va aussi être très serré pour
pouvoir examiner le texte on va finir
soit sur un 49-3 mais je crois pas que
ça soit la bonne solution sur un texte
comme celui-ci soit on va terminer sur
une commission mix paritaire qui
n'aboutira pas et qui sera pas
conclusive entre l'Assemblée et le Sénat
donc je crois qu'il y a encore peut-être
des signaux sans pour autant revenir sur
l'ambition de la retraite il y a des
choses sur lesquelles il faut pas voilà
il faut pas lâcher parce que je crois
que sinon on déshabille totalement la
philosophie même de la
[Musique]
on en parle très peu mais les députés du
rassemblement national l'ont évoqué
plusieurs fois ils l'ont évoqué et je
dois dire que sur ce sujet là ils ont
raison même si leur approche du sujet
est pas exactement celle qui est la
nôtre aujourd'hui mais en tout cas il
faut en parler il faut en parler alors
pendant les débats il y a des députés
modernes ont également proposé un
amendement pour en finir avec les 35
heures alors ça a fait
ça fait réagir vivement la gauche si
l'idée donc c'était si on travaille un
peu plus par semaine on pourrait donc
gagner deux ans sur notre date de départ
à la retraite finalement le gouvernement
a regretté a rejeté ce cet amendement
est-ce que vous le regrettez je pense
que le gouvernement là évidemment rejeté
parce qu'on touche à un totem un acquis
et c'est très difficile de revenir sur
certains acquis dans ce pays c'est un
acquis social mais on voit bien que le
passage au 35 heures a quand même
totalement bouleversé les choses moi je
je suis pas favorable autant de cinq
heures je pense qu'il faut donner de la
souplesse à chacun que ce soit du côté
des salariés ou du côté des employeurs
justement pour organiser le temps de
travail de façon différente l'idée de
l'amendement c'était pas d'imposer plus
de 35 heures pour tout le monde c'était
justement d'apporter cette cette
souplesse il y a d'autres amendements
qui font sens son expert qui pourront
aboutir mais voilà comme je le disais
par exemple sur les sur les femmes le
fait de pouvoir valoriser des carrières
qui malgré elles sont hachées et
notamment avec un congé maternité qui
plutôt d'être un handicap pour être un
bonus ça je pense que c'est quelque
chose d'intéressant et pareil pour un
amendement sur les seniors parce que la
difficulté qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est que
les seniors sont de moins en moins dans
l'emploi en tout cas arriver à leur
catégorie d'âge qui a un enjeu parfois
justement à les garder non pas un peu
plus longtemps mais au moins pour qu'il
finisse leur leur activité et leur vie
professionnelle jusqu'à l'âge de départ
et là l'idée c'était de voir des
cotisations patronales modules c'est à
dire que une entreprise payerait moins
de cotisations au régime des retraites
si il y a effectivement des seigneurs
dans ces effectifs donc il y a pas mal
de de sujets et d'idées qui sont sur la
table j'espère
dire que dans les jours prochains et
dans les différents débats que ce soit à
l'Assemblée ou au Sénat toutes ces idées
là pourront être débattues et le 7 mars
donc les syndicats appellent à mettre la
France à l'arrêt le leader de la France
insoumise Jean-Luc Mélenchon a appelé à
tout bloquer le gouvernement quoi qu'il
arrive ne devra pas céder à la pression
de la rue je bon déjà les débats sur les
retraites sont bien dans les hémicycles
et au sein de nos institutions qui
doivent avoir lieu c'est pas dans la rue
après il y a deux choses je pense qu'il
faut toujours écouter ce qui se dit dans
la rue en tout cas faut l'entendre
moi je suis pas sur une position
dogmatique ou jusqu'au-boutiste en
disant c'est ainsi on y va en mode
bulldozer et c'est le texte tel qu'il a
été déposé le premier jour qui doit
passer l'idée du débat parlementaire
c'est justement qu'on puisse l'enrichir
et se mettre d'accord mais en tout cas
tous les appels au blocage surtout au
moment où on va rentrer dans la période
des vacances scolaires c'est toujours de
la prise d'otage des Français on l'a vu
à Noël dernier où il y a des personnes
qui n'ont pas pu rejoindre leur famille
pour les c'est toujours très désagréable
on le voit dans le domaine des
transports
c'est pas c'est pas comme ça qu'on
arrive à avancer sur une réforme aussi
importante et donc faudra avancer
ensuite après la réforme des retraites
Emmanuel Macron voit déjà plus loin avec
la réforme des institutions leur est au
consultation pour le moment beaucoup de
sujets sont sur la table on verra ce qui
en ressort d'abord est-ce que c'est le
bon moment c'est le bon timing pour pour
cette réforme alors je vais vous dire le
le timing sera nécessairement bon dans
le sens où cette réforme on l'entend
depuis 2017 je rappelle que un
des éléments oui parce que enfin non
c'est pas trop tard il faut il faut la
faire je suis d'ailleurs satisfait
d'entendre le président de la République
remettre cette réforme sur la table
parce que c'était un des éléments qui a
fait que François bayraud a soutenu
Emmanuel Macron en 2017 c'était que
Emmanuel Macron avait avancé cette idée
de réforme des institutions avec un
point très important on parlait du
Parlement à l'instant et des blocages
qu'on peut connaître la fameuse c'est la
fameuse proportionnelle la
proportionnelle mais pas uniquement je
lisais dans un article du Canard
Enchaîné justement qui qui relayait
cette information comme quoi le
président souhaiterait engager cette
réforme des institutions le retour d'une
proposition qu'on portait il y a très
longtemps avec Jacqueline Gouraud à
l'époque où elle était vice-présidente
du Sénat et qui avait été aussi mis en
avant par le président Sarkozy c'est le
conseiller territorial ce fameux élu qui
pourrait siéger à la fois au département
et à la région donc il y a pas mal de
choses moi je suis très intéressé par
l'idée du président de la République de
revenir à un mandat
présidentiel unique soit 6 ans soit 7
ans avec peut-être des législatives qui
seront décorrélés amis mandat un peu à
l'américaine et moi ça c'est un système
qui me va bien puisque ça veut dire deux
choses ça veut dire que on pourrait
corriger à la fois non pas les dérives
mais les dysfonctionnements de la
Cinquième République tout en mettant à
la fois et bien du pouvoir du côté de
l'exécutif mais aussi du Parlement
aujourd'hui la vraie difficulté qu'on a
dans la Cinquième République c'est que
le Parlement est notamment l'Assemblée
nationale finalement a très peu de
pouvoir de décision et puis sa
responsabiliserait l'ensemble des forces
politiques qui au lieu d'être dans
l'ajout de verbale et dans l'opposition
permanente là aurait les moyens en tout
cas de travailler convenablement avec
avec l'ensemble des collègues de
l'Assemblée vous avez parlé donc de la
proportionnelle pour donc élire les
députés de l'Assemblée nationale est-ce
que ce nombre de députés est trop
nombreux aujourd'hui il y en a 577
est-ce qu'il faut le baisser ou ce genre
j'ai jamais considéré qu'il y avait trop
de trop d'élus ça je crois que c'est un
discours qui est parfois un peu un peu
populiste je trouve le sujet c'est pas
le nombre d'élus le sujet c'est
l'efficacité de l'institution dans
laquelle il siège et cette proportionnel
du coup comment elle s'organiserait
selon vous il y a plusieurs il y a
plusieurs possibilités ça peut être des
scrutins de liste au niveau
départemental donc une proportionnelle
par département par département c'est
d'ailleurs le cas dans les départements
dans les départements aussi ruraux
finalement donc ça peut être dans les
départements ça peut être à des échelons
régionaux alors peut-être pas les
grandes régions françaises d'ailleurs
j'ai vu que le Président de la
République souhaitait peut-être revenir
sur le découpage des certaines régions
notamment le grand est notamment ça peut
s'entendre on va l'Aquitaine ça peut
s'entendre mais en tout cas je crois pas
que les élus au dernier Rhône-Alpes et
envie qu'on redessine totalement la
carte des régions parce que ça ça nous a
fait quand même beaucoup de mal on a
besoin de stabilité que ce soit
peut-être sur un ou deux cas pourquoi
pas mais pas Carole Delga la présidente
des régions de France est président de
la Région Occitanie s'il y a déjà
vivement t'opposé je peux comprendre de
leur point de vue que ce soit compliqué
de d'engager une nouvelle réforme sur ce
sujet là autre sujet aussi depuis 2017
les parlementaires que ce soit les
députés ou les sénateurs non plus le
droit d'être mère ou mère adjoint d'une
ville d'être président ou vice-président
d'une région ou d'un département donc
c'était la fin du fameux cumul des
mandats aujourd'hui la question de d'un
retour de ce cumulait en bas peut se
poser notamment pour les la possibilité
pour un député d'être maire d'une petite
commune qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
sur ce sujet là moi je trouve que à
l'époque on a pris le sujet à l'envers
c'est à dire que on voulait des
parlementaires qui soient j'aime pas
cette expression mais le reflet de la
société civile et donc il y a eu cette
interdiction de non-cumules là où je
pense qu'on s'est planté je dis nous
mais finalement c'est pouvoir politique
de l'époque ça c'est comme ça quand même
été voté sous François Hollande
je crois que le débat était pas tant le
cumul des fonctions ce qui pouvait
choquer parfois les Français c'était le
cumul des indemnités tout en sachant en
plus que les élus sont plafonnées à
partir d'un certain montant et puis la
disponibilité qu'on peut consacrer un
mandat mais d'un côté aujourd'hui quel
est le premier reproche qu'on fait au
député de la législature actuelle et de
la précédente on les qualifie dors seul
on leur dit ils sont hors sol parce
qu'ils n'ont pas d'ancrage dans les
territoires ils sont pas élus local etc
etc bon moi je trouve ça dommageable je
j'ai travaillé à l'Assemblée je trouve
qu'on a des députés qui font le travail
qui font le boulot on a une Assemblée
nationale qui représente quand même un
peu mieux en termes de profil les
Français que qu'auparavant néanmoins sur
le nom cumule je pense qu'il y a un
chemin à faire l'idée c'est pas de rétro
près de rétropédaler et dire qu'il faut
annuler la loi telle qu'elle avait été
votée auparavant
mais ne serait-ce que la fonction
d'adjoint
adjoint au maire et parlementaire
devrait être des fonctions qui puissent
être cumulables je crois que c'est
important pour un député pour un
sénateur surtout parce que là on parle
de l'Assemblée mais le Sénat le Sénat
c'est quand même la chambre de repris
des représentants des communes c'est
quand même très difficile d'avoir des
sénateurs qui n'est pas d'ancrage local
alors mère peut-être je dirais jusqu'à
un certain nombre d'habitants ça me
paraît un petit peu compliqué
aujourd'hui d'être mère d'une commune
très très dense en population d'une
grande d'une grande métropole et
d'occuper la fonction de parlementaire
peut-être pour des communes un peu de
moindre taille et puis surtout moi je
pense au moins les fonctions d'adjoint
je crois que c'est important pour un
parlementaire d'avoir la tête dans des
dossiers territoriaux locaux et de
garder finalement une prise avec le
terrain on va passer maintenant à la
deuxième partie de l'île de politique
l'hebdo-politiques
[Musique]
toujours avec Jean-Baptiste amonique
mère modem de Villepreux on parlait
justement de la réforme des institutions
à l'instant l'engagement citoyen c'est
la grande cause de la ville de Villepin
2023 alors pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
fait ce choix cette année on a lancé
alors déjà on a acté à Villepreux qu'on
aurait chaque année une grande cause
municipale liée à une politique publique
qu'on fait priorité sur sur la commune
2022 c'était l'inclusion du handicap
alors ça veut pas dire que au 31
décembre on arrête totalement on
continue mais c'est pour pouvoir
enclencher des choses sur 2023 c'est
l'engagement citoyen pourquoi parce que
on parlait de la réforme des
institutions on sent que les pouvoirs
publics quels qu'ils soient et notamment
les collectivités ont un rôle à jouer
dans l'accompagnement de nos administrer
de nos populations à pouvoir et bien
porter leur projet quel qu'il soit et
des projets qui viennent finalement
favoriser et encourager la citoyenneté à
l'occasion de cette journée à laquelle
on a madame la qui est venu nous rendre
visite puisqu'elle est en charge de la
jeunesse et notamment du SNU du service
national universel on a mis en avant
plusieurs outils plusieurs dispositifs
locaux on a créé un Conseil de la ville
locale qui est notre instance de
participation citoyenne qui est composé
de plusieurs comités thématiques on a
annoncé la création à venir d'un conseil
municipal junior parce que je crois que
c'est dès le plus jeune âge qu'on peut
donner l'envie aux jeunes et bien de
s'engager et notamment à un échelon de
proximité il y a tout le volet aussi
accompagnement de la vie et du tissu
associatif parce qu'aujourd'hui je crois
pas qu'on parle souvent de crise de
l'engagement moi c'est pas ce que je
constate sur le terrain parce que je
croise tous les jours des personnes qui
me disent comment est-ce qu'on peut
faire pour s'engager donner un peu de
notre temps donc on a une société qui
reste surtout à Villepreux mais on a une
société qui reste très généreuse et très
dans l'envie voilà de faire du bénévolat
et d'être solidaire envers les autres
mais il faut pouvoir l'organiser donc
c'est pour ça qu'aussi dans le soutien à
la vie associative on a une plateforme
qui permet de mettre en relation les
associations et leurs besoins et un
tissu de bénévoles potentiel mais qui
souhaite n'ont pas s'engager toute une
année au sein d'une même association
mais venir ponctuellement aller aider
les Restos du Coeur participer à
l'organisation des manifestations du
Téléthon être commissaire pour une
course être voilà donc tout ça on essaye
de l'organiser pour pour le faire vivre
il y a évidemment aussi le service
national universel qui pour moi est un
magnifique dispositif de l'État qui
permet aux jeunes et bien après un stage
d'accomplir des missions aussi d'intérêt
général c'est de la cohésion nationale
tout simplement ce le SNU c'est de la
cohésion nationale et j'espère en tout
cas la ministre porte ce sujet et je
crois que Emmanuel Macron présent de la
République et d’accord avec avec cette
idée j'espère que le SNU pourra être
généralisé en tout cas nous nous
accueillons des des jeunes du SNU à
Villepreux et j'encourage tous les
jeunes qui voudraient s'orienter vers
cette voie à parler avec eux parce que
c'est vraiment une expérience
exceptionnelle vous êtes également
Jean-Baptiste amonique vice-président en
charge des questions de transport et des
mobilité durables à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines les transports
justement c'est un sujet très important
pour les franciliens et pour tous les
habitants de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
j'aimerais revenir avec vous sur le
projet et all du coup Clément Beaune à
l'occasion d'un déplacement de Clément
Beaune à Porte Maillot les élus de la
région Île-de-France Valérie Pécresse
pierre bélier président du Conseil
général des Yvelines départementales
monsieur Siffredi également pour les
Hauts-de-Seine et Anne Hidalgo pour la
mairie de Paris ont organisé une
conférence de presse surprise pour
justement critiquer l'action du
gouvernement et reprocher donc ses
retards sur ce projet près de deux ans
de retard à cause du covid mais aussi
deux milliards de déficits les élus
locaux finalement rejettent la faute sur
l'état ils ont raison dans ce dossier
non je crois qu'il se trompe parce que
déjà c'est jamais bon de dans une
politique un peu de la chaise vide et
pas cuir le ministre quand il vient sur
un déplacement je crois que c'est c'est
pas une attitude voilà ils auraient pu
faire autrement on va le dire comme ça
sur le fond l'État a on fait le
contraire depuis deux trois ans l'État a
toujours été au rendez-vous des
transports des transports en commun
franciliens vous avez évoqué la crise
covid la crise covid faut pas oublier
que l'État a quand même alloué 2
milliards d'euros à Île-de-France
mobilité faut pas oublier que cette
année il y a une subvention
exceptionnelle de l'état de 200 millions
d'euros à Île-de-France mobilité et que
cette subventions qui permet à Valérie
Pécresse président de l'Île-de-France
mobilité d'avoir une augmentation du
tarif du Pass Navigo qui reste modérée
acceptable et de pas avoir un passe
Navigo qui froulerait les 100 euros et
pour Éole l'état s'y est engagé et de la
rappeler ce sont 605 millions d'euros
qui vont être déployés et mis sur la
table quant au calendrier il est ce
qu'il est il a été un petit peu retardé
je pense que tout le monde peut le
comprendre on regarde de la période
qu'on a traversé moi ce que je regrette
c'est que finalement c'est le conférence
de presse elle rouvre un débat de
comment financer les transports en
Île-de-France or on a eu des assises on
a eu des rencontres il y a un mois et
demi à la région avec l'État le ministre
était là avec Valérie Pécresse et on est
déjà tous autour de la table pour
essayer de trouver des solutions
pérennes pour financer les transports
donc il faut pas rejouer le match ou en
tout cas je pense que c'est inutile de
faire de la polémique de cette façon là
je pense qu'il faut plutôt qu'on
continue à travailler tous ensemble
comme c'est le cas déjà depuis plusieurs
semaines donc bon moi j'ai bon espoir en
tout cas au-delà de cette petite sortie
médiatique que l'ensemble des élus
franciliens continuent à se mobiliser
dans des conditions un peu plus voilà un
peu plus favorables à 50 ans en Yvelines
mais en tout cas la ligne qui intéresse
grandement du projet Grand Paris Express
et la ligne 18 qui est attendue à la
reliera donc Versailles à l'aéroport de
Paris Orly en passant donc par 50 ans en
Yvelines la mise en service est invendue
environ en 2030 pas de retard prévu pour
le moment écoutez moi j'étais avec la
Société du Grand Paris Grand Paris
Express la semaine dernière le
calendrier de 30 et maintenu donc pour
le moment les voyants sont ouverts on a
d'ailleurs hier soir en conseil
communautaire de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à l'unanimité
fait formuler un vœu que la future gare
puisse être baptisée Guyancourt
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines celle qui
était appelé jusqu'à maintenant 50 ans
est donc les voyants sont ouverts en
tout cas le projet est majoritairement
soutenu par les élus de l'agglomération
du département des parlementaires aussi
il va apporter un véritable plus au
territoire et notamment sur un
territoire où on le sait le tissu
économique qui dépend des mobilités et
de l'axé aux transports pour finir cette
émission Jean-Baptiste harmonique un mot
sur ce vote du Parlement européen qui a
voté donc la semaine dernière la fin de
la vente des voitures thermiques neuves
en 2021 en 2035 une décision qui peut
provoquer certaines inquiétudes on aura
maintenant donc 12 ans pour se préparer
qu'est-ce qui est fait aujourd'hui à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour se
préparer et le message du Parlement
européen c'est clairement passons à
l'électrique oui alors moi je considère
qu'il faut pas qu'on mette tous nos œufs
dans le même panier et que le mix
énergétique que ce soit pour la
politique énergétique de l'État ou dans
les transports il faut il faut le faire
valoir on peut pas dire on met toute
notre énergie et toute notre en tout cas
tous nos tous nos priorités sur un seul
et même mode que ce soit voilà
l'électricité électrique ou autre en
revanche moi je suis plutôt satisfait de
la décision de leur l'Union européenne
participe à la décision et l'objectif de
neutralité carbone à 2050 là où
effectivement il va y avoir un enjeu ça
va être l'accompagnement
l'accompagnement des particuliers mais
aussi l'accompagnement des industriels
de l'automobile c'est là où se situe les
plus grosses inquiétudes forcément
evidemment alors là je crois savoir que
des choses sont prévues du côté de
l'Union européenne avec ce qu'ils
appellent le fond social pour le climat
ou un certain nombre de mesures
d'accompagnement et de soutien devrait
être proposé au secteur de l'industrie
il faudra je pense aussi pousser le
marché de l'occasion la seconde main sur
électrique et puis pour suivre aussi
avec l'hybride en en tout cas
Saint-Quentin on le fait alors on est
moins sur la sur le véhicule individuel
encore que vous savez on a déployé start
Sky qui est l'ensemble de bornes
électriques deepornierve sur sur le
territoire parce que c'est bien d'avoir
des véhicules électriques mais il faut
avoir un maillage territorial en borne
qui permet effectivement de pouvoir se
recharger donc il y a encore du travail
c'est bien que l'Union européenne puisse
poser comme ça des actes forts
maintenant comme je le dis assez souvent
dans transition énergétique énergétique
c'est bien mais transition faut pas
l'oublier et ça ça nécessite des mesures
d'accompagnement merci beaucoup
Jean-Baptiste amonique d'avoir été avec
nous dans le livre de politique ce soir
je rappelle donc que vous êtes le maire
de Villepreux et président du MoDem 78
nous on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro de
l'hebdo-politique sur Radio sensation
très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]